right so when moving into the third
dimension by looking at you generate the
divisions reliving okay by when you
study on with these shapes prison no you
said yes noise answer just wait for
everyone to be ready I'd like to give
you a jam-packed definition yeah and so
because it's so dense I want to make
sure you get all the pieces I'll give
you the sentence and then we'll explain
it bit by bit
so four styles a prism is giving me a 3d
shape okay with now this is important
with cross-sections I can fit cross
sections that are last uniform a prism
is a 3d shape with cross sections that
are uniform polygons okay there's a lot
of words there it's very densely packed
let's let's unfold I'm actually going to
skip this I'll come back to this word in
a second - it comes on a 3d shape right
that means of course it's got length and
it's not weird
what else would it have over here okay
now both of these I like this way and
then this way if I combine everything
together I get volume what's the third
thing I must combine with it to get more
high very good
so it's like kind of flat on the ground
and then if I add height in combined I
won't forget them give me board you we
can how much space it takes about their
ages okay next thing we're on path cross
sections right so section just means
cutting something up right so for
example you might know when pregnant
mothers are giving birth the other
natural birth although have what we call
the cesarean section so it's
okay sorry yeah because it's the more
sanctions okay you might say ah my
assignment has three sections in it
right all that means is you can cut it
into three pieces that's all to them
what do you think this would cross adds
to it what do you hold on I didn't keep
you because some people being really
loud could you repeat I still can't hear
you
unfortunately she's really disappointing
because I'd love to be able to hear
someone's contribution to the class
third time lucky can we try again okay
what do you mean by the way intercept
okay so this is a bit tricky this part
before now I'm just going to take the
same word and I'm gonna say sections is
cutting right cross I'm gonna take the
same way this right it has a cross right
this will be a lot easier with pictures
so I'll get to that in a second okay now
Stewart two more words three more words
on that uniform you guys wear uniforms
what does uniform mean okay yeah
fantastic all the same another word you
want another pair of words that you'll
see in here can someone give me like an
a synonym for uniform all the same
finish same is fine yeah say it's right
how about if you've got two twins and
they look exactly the same we caught up
identical twins or a more math see sort
of word which you've seen before and
we'll meet again is the word congruent
or congruent okay I think you can do it
both ways all of these uniform identical
congra they mean the same thing that
they're the same
last one
fala goods what's a polygon not to be
confused with Paragon does anyway yes
okay
he's my definition you know how we had a
3d shape up here that's the prism or
polygons well I should say no polygons
are 3d shapes because polygons are too
deep so it's a 2d shape but in addition
to that right for example a circle we
love circles but circles are not
polygons why not what is it about
polygons that makes a circle not one
yeah it's a 2d shape weird and all the
way saying science is straight edges
right and a circle does not have
straight angles okay
lovely now the last word is to unpassed
prison but I'll come back to that after
I show you some examples so with the
help of some other people I've made some
physics groups so here we go here's a
prison okay now just think about how
this fits into this okay
is it 3d yes length width height cross
sections if I were to take this shape
right and cut it across like this okay I
can cut it across and I'll be cutting
across again and I can cut it across
again and whatever I get all of these
guys are have a look what are they they
are these are all uniform polygons you
get it and does that make sense
now we name prisons according to what
kind of polygon you get when you take a
cross-section when you cut it across
right so these guys are these guys are
squares cause it's worth noting let me
put this back together it's worth
learning you can see I've cut it across
this way so I get all these squares
right this particular shape I could cut
a few different ways right how else
could I cut it okay so I could cut it
like when you say it down the middle
which way do I'm gonna cut down the
middle
this site this way women tell you
through my hands okay I could go
horizontal right now have a look for a
second yeah I can't do it because my
shape is not put together this way but
if I cut this one out here I just
imagine me taking that and slicing off
the front okay what will be left behind
what's going in that behind this shape
it's gonna be exactly the same isn't it
you're gonna get pink orange brown
yellow green you're still gonna get
beautiful polygons does that make sense
okay all right now this is pretty boring
it's pretty boring I brought some more
interesting polygons
okay presumes I should say a little bit
maybe this is still upon us right this
is still a prison how do I know it's
still a prison okay it's still 3d if I
take a cross-section
turns out that cross-section if I take a
cross section like this what do I need
my cross-section to be exactly the same
all the way of all right and you can see
it is uh how about this guy hold on I'm
gonna put this one back to cut off what
do you think it looks weird it looks
weird because of the shape that I / DN
a-- but is this a polygon yes all the
edges are straight and they're all the
same one last one here we go
but but well you gets a pyramid but look
all the cross-sections are squares okay
so there are all squares but they're
different sizes
aren't they so they are not identical
they're not congruent right so this is
not a prison it's a pyramid okay all
right so you know what prisms are now
last bit I said I'd come back to swim
prison actually comes from a word that
means you might want to write this down
can you take an ultra option object
rather and usour it into pieces comes
from the the word to saw why do you
think they would have used that as our
word for prism yeah yeah very good
just actually taking it off like if you
had say a tree right you'd have to soar
across here and that would give you your
cross-section